c two zero zero zero one
up next an interview with radio and tv
personality casey kasem mr kasem is an
anti-war activist and member of the arab
american anti-discrimination league he
is of lebanese descent and grew up in
detroit michigan for the past 21 years
mr kasem has hosted his weekly top 40
music countdown heard on more than 450
radio stations worldwide he spoke with
us this week from his hollywood home and
is part of c-span's continuing coverage
of the war in the middle east and
reaction both at home and abroad
[Music]
casey kasem this war is now in its
fourth week what role do you see
hollywood playing so far in this
conflict
well hollywood has been rather silent
with the exception of mike farrell ron
kovic
there are a few others
that have been outspoken
i can't think of them all right now ed
asner they're a handful woody
harrelson
and a few producers
but those that have been at the rallies
have been few
but i have a feeling that just
underneath
the surface
a lot of people waiting to speak out
just waiting to be asked
why are you speaking out
because i think war is archaic i think
it's ancient
i think it's uncivilized i think it has
no place in the 21st century
it has no place now that we have no evil
enemy
we have the the
biggest country in the world
the biggest military in the world
now let's be the greatest country in the
world
and teach the world really how to be
kinder and gentler we can do that we
have that window of opportunity for the
first time and we didn't take advantage
of it
let's talk a bit about your own values
what helped shaped the values of casey
kasem and the beliefs which you now have
about war and about what's been going on
over there
i think my parents had a lot to do with
my my mother always taught me to
to believe that god was right by my side
at all times i had nothing to fear and
that i should
try anything
uh just don't step in anyone's toes
getting to where you're going
basic philosophy
helping people would help you succeed
more than anything easiest way to
succeed help somebody else succeed
and i think that's the approach i've
i've had in my career and i'd like to
think that's the reason i've been
successful it's certainly not because
i'm the most talented person in the
world
or the most intelligent person in the
world but
i think because what my parents gave me
and what they bought from the old
country from lebanon from the mideast
was a sense of uh
of importance
a sense of knowing that i can make a
difference as an individual
and that loving people
is first and foremost and that your name
is the most important thing that you can
take with you when you go
you grew up in detroit
detroit's home and i would would not
have wanted to grow up anywhere else but
detroit i grew up
there and i was fortunate enough to be
in school with at a time when schools
and perhaps some of the other parts of
the country for one reason or another
didn't have blacks or jews or hispanics
etc
we had a little bit of everything when i
was growing up in detroit and that was
healthy
what do you think what did you think on
january 15th
when whether it was on the radio or on
television you heard that the war had
begun
i was doing amen i was guesting on the
tv show amen
a bunch of people were watching
television in
in one of the rooms i said what happened
haven't you heard it broke out we had
just finished rehearsal
and i didn't think it was going to
happen i truly believed
that the president
had so many options
he had sanctions he had embargo he had
blockade
he had the arabs that could have
straightened it out
he had time on his side
and he didn't take that opportunity to
show the world
that there are other ways to solve our
problems
and that if we're ever going to be
civilized
ever
it has to start with someone
and why not with the most powerful
country in the world with the most
powerful person in the world our
president
and what we tried to do in peace
movement
those who opposed the war
and felt that
that there were other options
was to through rallies
through letters
through talking on television and radio
shows such as this one
to let america know that every one of us
counts
body counts are important
if a million people are at washington in
front of the white house saying mr
president
find another way
he's going to listen
with both ears maybe not with just one
ear well we went to washington and we
marched and we had about seventy five
thousand the first time and i guess over
a hundred thousand a second time and two
hundred thousand in san francisco
and uh
and around the world there were millions
that were protesting in europe in
australia
in southeast asia
it should have sent a message that
something is happening
to the world community
when that wall came down
in berlin
that was the greatest symbol in the
world that that said to the world
finally maybe there will be peace in our
time
maybe
thinkers
will become
leaders or leaders
will become thinkers
and will look for other alternatives
and mr bush had them right in front of
him
he had it all
he could have gone down as the greatest
man of the century
and he could have done it with no one
dying
and he chose
the customary thing
i think it was
george bernard shaw who said
custom will reconcile people to any
atrocity
and it's been customary for the world
since the beginning of man to solve the
problems with a club
with a gun
we watch it on television every night it
is acceptable because
it's custom
you have bull fighting
bull gets killed
the bull is tortured before he's killed
it's customary dog fighting [ __ ]
fighting
i suggest that what we had going on
between
two presidents
saddam hussein and president george bush
was a [ __ ] fight
you mentioned the protest rallies and we
have shown them as well as the other
networks
and the one
sense that we get from those people who
talk about the media's role in all of
this
is that these protest rallies are
unpatriotic my question is what do you
say to those people who say that
by doing
by having these marches by having these
demonstrations it's an unpatriotic thing
to do at this time
well all we have to do is look back on
on other wars
in hindsight we find out that the people
who complained the most
for instance abraham lincoln was against
the war with with mexico he lost his
seat in congress because he opposed it
uh
emerson against the war with mexico
henry david thoreau went to jail for
civil disobedience
and uh
and and felt that we shouldn't be
fighting with mexico and many americans
in hindsight when we look back on it now
we laugh laughed
yeah we stole it from mexico we really
stole it from the indians we really
stole it from this and stole it
but that's after a hundred years then we
all laugh about it
it isn't so funny
to the people whose conscience tell them
that there's something wrong here
two and two is not making four
and so they act out they don't play it
safe they don't play it politic
they don't play it popular they say no
i'm going to protest now some of them
have no restraint
some do crazy things they'll burn a flag
not realizing that this is a symbol to a
lot of people
to the parents of someone who died in
the second world war or the first world
war or
whatever war
uh it's it's it's so much of a symbol
you can't do that
and what happens is
if you have
one person doing that
in 75 000
the press tends to exploit
and where are they going to go hey guys
burning the flag quick you guys over
here grab that aha and he's stepping on
it get that shot
now i'm not condemning the press
they're going to go with what people are
going to tune into people want to see
action that's what they're used to
unfortunately
the guy who came there with his baby
daughter
and mom who's got a picture of her son
who's a marine in saudi arabia
and an old man who lost his sight in the
first world war
you don't see those people
they're quiet they don't demonstrate
they're there because their conscience
tells them they have to be there because
it's right and they know
that they may not have other resources
they may not be able to write letters
they may not be good at writing
they may feel that a letter to the
editor doesn't mean anything and they
forget how important it can be or to an
editor
or to a radio talk show host etc they're
beginning to learn that that does have
impact but they're there at least
they're putting their bodies on the line
too many of us
too many of us
uh
tend to be big talkers
and not doers
big talkers
i was a big talker during the vietnam
where i knew all the answers i knew we
shouldn't have been there and i told
everybody i knew about it
that was about 12 people
i should have been out there in the
lines
i should have done what brian wilson did
he lost his legs
trying to stop a train
saying don't send any munitions to the
contrast
because he believed that was wrong
that's not the way you stop a war is to
give
to feed
to feed the munitions to kill more
people
you come to the bargaining table you
negotiate you do some comprehensive
looking at all of central america all of
south america our whole foreign policy
and you look back on it and you say
who have our friends been
well we teamed up with noriega
and then he lost popularity
we were big with marcos for many many
years he lost poppier popularity there
was gm
there was pinochet
there was batista there was samosa there
was saddam hussein
for eight years
he's using the same weapons that we sold
him
to defend the
defender's country
so what we have to do
all america has to start rethinking
the potential of this country
i think we're the only country that has
the potential to go
above and beyond ourselves as human
beings
uh
into a strata that's that's
it's
far more spiritual
uh
into an area that's uh
[Music]
far more understanding than we've ever
been and that's to
to look at other people
as we see ourselves
and michael jackson said it well when he
said the man in the mirror
and the man in the mirror is us and the
enemy sometimes is us
and we have to recognize that while
while we we're a great democracy
that we hide behind the flag sometimes
we hide behind words like liberty and
justice and righteousness and freedom
and
what happens is it gets us into trouble
if you were in a position of authority
what would you have done differently
first off
i would have
done it through the united nations
i'm not sure i would have bought off
certain countries i'm not sure i would
have made a deal with
egypt
because i almost feel as though they
didn't do it because they wanted to do
it they did it because we forgave a debt
uh
the soviet union did it because they got
four billion dollars from the saudis and
a few billion from us and a few promises
and so on it went down the line that way
that's manipulation
that's the problem we've had in the
united nations
is manipulation
there have been times when the
government the united states government
didn't vote with 156 other people
and as a result uh because they
they were in the security council the
resolution didn't pass and yet there
there were resolutions that were passed
despite the united nations the the votes
the votes carried or the united states
and
i would have done that
to see if the u.n would join me and i
think they would have
i think they would have for the right
reasons
because there was an aggression
and it was wrong
and two wrongs aren't going to make a
right
one war
creating another war
doesn't make make it right it merely
plants the seeds for the next war
i think i would have used humanitarian
uh
not necessarily a blockade because
that's an act of war in itself
but i think i would have done
done the other things
and that is uh
prevent them from getting
war supplies and embargo
and make sure that the other nations
worked with us on it and i think it's
just a matter of time
and if it had taken 10 years
if you total up the cost
of the number of people it'll die
and the cost
in the amount of money that is spent
that could have
gone to save the dying people in this
country
the dying people in the third world but
let's get back to this country the
homeless
the illiterate
37 million people who have no health
insurance
the people who are one and two steps
away from being homeless
they're living from paycheck to paycheck
the children one in five who go to bed
hungry every night
the wars that we should be fighting here
those are the wars we should be
concerned about and not spending our
money
on the kind of uh
kind of dead end things
products like war products
that we have been
it could have
worked
it was working in just the few days that
we started doing it was working
unfortunately it was working because
some of the children were getting
aspirin some of the children weren't
getting antibiotics
and they were dying
so i think humanitarian
embargo sanctions would have been the
way to do it and i think ultimately
there would have been some agreement
he would have removed his troops there
would have been some agreement the
kuwaitis uh perhaps would have
uh rather to see their whole country
decimated and totally destroyed and
that's what's going to happen now
and spending billions and billions to
repair it
the lives could have been saved the
money could have been saved and what
they may have what they may have had to
give up for that
would more than been worth it certainly
in american lives certainly in the wives
of kuwaitis and others who are going to
be fighting there
and the lives that
here at home that are wasted year after
year after year and we don't do anything
about it isn't it strange there's always
enough money for war
always enough money for war no problem
we find it some way
and yet when we have three million
americans homeless
we don't find the money for that
we don't find the money for the
young people who have to join the army
because they can't get loans to go to
college
etc
so
i think the kinder gentler
new world way
would be
the easiest way
and that is not to go to war
not to spend the peace dividend
on on on a brand new war
earlier this week
hollywood announced that uh song voices
that care is going to be performed by
people like meryl streep and paul
mccartney and the beach boys
do you think that we will see more of a
dialogue on this issue in this town from
people like yourselves on both sides of
the issue
in the first place
what what people who
who suspect anti-war people
must realize
is that
we are in support of our our warriors
just not the war
we love those those people so much we
want to see them come back as soon as
possible and take the dollars that we're
now spending on gas masks
and on missiles and on tanks
and on planes and on aircraft carriers
and on atomic weapons and hydrogen bombs
and put those same people
through school
give those same people an opportunity at
jobs
that's what we should be doing
and
and what's so strange is we are in a
position to do that
we were able to clean up the snl's or at
least we're going to in the next 30
years to the tune of what maybe a
trillion dollars but we're going to do
it
and yet we've got a war going on
every single day of our life there are
parts of the united states of america
washington dc included
detroit
l.a
new york city
where you you'd be afraid to walk with
your family
for fear you might get killed
now
in order to solve the problems of the
gangs
we just can't go out and hire more
policemen
we have to know why those young people
join gangs
what it is what created it poverty
uh
illiteracy etc
we really have to start getting to the
root of our problems
we keep covering it up we keep covering
it up and instead of
instead of going to the root and digging
it out
beginning with love
and compassion toward our fellow man
as as the equation
we tend to go the easy route
the
the so-called easy level and that is
hey guy gives you trouble
knock his block off
like to read a quote this is the the
quote that you
had in this morning's usa today article
you said that all germans are not judged
by hitler all cambodians are not judged
by paul pot nor all panamanians by
noriega
you obviously are then also referring to
your own background of course all
palestinians or arabs should not be
judged by abu nadal
all israelis should not be judged by
ariel sharon
and you can keep going right down the
line not that i'm i don't want to
trivialize hitler
by putting these other people in the
same class
maybe paul pott is nearing that class he
just wiped out half of his own people in
cambodia but these other people uh
there are a lot of there's a i mean a
lot of people can share it and if we go
back and look at what happened to the
natives in this country
the blacks in this country
and some of the people who were
responsible for it who could have
changed it
i'm afraid that some of the heroes that
we look back on wouldn't be the heroes
that we once thought they were
uh
you know
it's hard to even imagine today
tell a young person that
that african americans that blacks
couldn't get on a bus
and when they did
had to go to the back
where they couldn't drink out of a
fountain
or they couldn't go to a restaurant
but
it's almost hard to believe and yet
in 1956 or seven or eight when when nat
king cole
the greatest balladeer in american
history
had a television show on cbs network
nobody would sponsor it it was
sustaining without sponsorship and he
had guest stars and were superstars
but the sponsors were afraid if they
sponsored somebody who was black
it could reflect on their their good
products
look at today
it changed
and uh
and today the superstars of television
men and women and children are black
and uh
opportunities are there and and
and all of a sudden you you look at a
people who were once demonized as
something less than human
all of a sudden they're just as
intelligent just as talented uh just as
human as anybody anywhere
and
hollywood unfortunately through the
years
going back even the
with the with african americans in what
was the picture tolerance uh not
tolerance uh
uh birth of a nation
i mean who was the heavy
the black guy
uh then uh they did the same things to
the asian pacifics they never trusted
them they were slant-eyed and they were
you always suspected they were they were
gonna they're knightly in the back
uh the arabs they were women womanizers
and not to be trusted either
and also knife-wielding or
sword-wielding are the hispanics well
they were just lazy and never did
anything you know
and
this is the way hollywood portrayed
ethnic groups
uh when the irish first came to this
country they had problems the jews as
well
now the arabs
have experienced it for since the sheik
in 1920 21 when that movie was first
first released
and there were some 86 other films in
that decade
with the same theme
a womanizer you know
fighter in the desert
now we have a situation where
arabs are fighting arabs americans are
fighting arabs
and
this will be fuel for the bigots
because you see all of a sudden
there will be more films whether the
arabs will be the bad guys
and it'll be on our front pages
when we see body bags coming back
this will be fuel for people who
discriminate
people who are prejudiced it won't be
the majority of the americans
99 percent of the american people say
look they're good and bad in all
ethnicities
in all races all religions
but they'll be that handful
and that's what they look for
they did it to hitler and hitler did it
to the jews
back in the 30s so that he was able to
send them off to the gas chambers
near the end of the war in the 40s
and not too many people
even if they knew about it did anything
about it
even though there were german heroes who
tried to prevent it
what's happening now
is here we have this history
this buildup
of
the arab being a bomber a billionaire a
belly dancer a terrorist
and
now suddenly we're at war with the arabs
more pictures like that will come on the
screen the old pictures will be there to
reinforce the image so
i'm happy to say that
the american arab discrimination
committee the national association of
arab americans the arab american
institute other organizations that are
non-arab as well
will do whatever they can to see if we
can't turn that image around
because it's going to hurt the children
in school
there's already a stack this thick of
pages over just the past month
of
problems in schools at the workplace
uh at mosques and so on
where
people have uh
have been nasty so
i'm happy to say that there will be
those who will try to counteract that
and i came from a meeting just a couple
of hours ago of about 10 very very
talented producers television and radio
shows and motion pictures and we sat and
we started thinking about the
possibility of creating some commercials
that would give a good identity
to arab americans and arabs and people
of this
islamic religion
and the reason we did that is because
i'm happy to say that fox television
in los angeles channel 11 when we went
there to talk about uh their
broadcasting of
the wrestling show where they have a
couple of nasty arabs
and we registered a complaint and they
said you're right that isn't right so
they called the company and to see what
they could do about it to have those
folks removed
but they came up with another idea they
said look what can we do to help
we couldn't believe it
so my associates and i
said well
and they said how about some spot
announcements some commercials
that's terrific
and so that's why we got together with
these people who are our friends and
associates in the business and show
business to talk about what it is we
could do to talk about maybe people like
mainstream americans who people don't
know are arab americans like
ralph nader
and
senator george mitchell
senate majority leader uh
john sununu white house chief of staff
dr michael debakey the scientist and the
inventor and
the one who uh who prepares uh who pairs
broken hearts
people who are like
in your business the dean of the white
house press corps helen thomas an arab
american and in sports you have the
coach of ucla jim herrick and jeff
george the number one draft choice last
year in the nfl now playing for the
colts quarterback and the heisman trophy
winner doug flutie into the miracle pass
for boston a few years ago and the race
car driver who won the indianapolis 500
bobby ray hall
the world's first jet ace
during the korean war first man to knock
down five enemy planes
in a jet
with an arab american that they give an
award for every year
and he's colonel james jabara u.s air
force arab american
and then you have college presidents and
you have school teachers astronauts
remember when the challenger went down
there was an african-american
there was an asian pacific
there was a jewish american
there was a wasp
few people realized there was an arab
american named christa mcauliffe
these are the things that we want to do
we want to say look we're the most loyal
people in this country no more loyal
than anybody else but no less
we're americans and we're proud of it
but we're also proud of our heritage
just as a hundred million other
americans identify with their ethnicity
we do too
we feel it's part of what makes us good
americans
my mother
got her
her sense of morality
her sense of spirituality from the old
country she brought it over with her
danny thomas's parents did the same
thing
god bless him late danny thomason for
what he did for air of americans in the
in the name of saint jude children's
research hospital
that'll be his legacy not to mention all
the people he made laugh and cry through
the years
every ethnic group has
has that right to be proud and stand
tall because they're arab americans or
jewish americans or
native americans
or whatever they are
and
we have to remind people that that's
what makes this country great
and when one ethnic group
has its toes stepped on
then we are denigrating we are
defaming
all ethnic groups
because when is it going to be
your turn
what would the spot say without giving a
hollywood secret the right way what will
it uh include what message you've talked
about some of it right now
but if you could write the script what
would you want in the script
i if i do that i i
there were so many good ideas that if i
throw some out there let me see
well you you might say uh
you might have what's your ethnicity
irish okay
okay you would come on and you'd uh
give your name and say and i'm an
irish-american
you know some of my best friends are
arabs one of them is a football player
who threw this miracle touchdown pass
six years ago for boston college his
name
doug flutie a loyal american and proud
of it an arab american bank something
like that i mean that's just throwing
one out
uh
but there are a lot of ways to go we can
do it through humor too we can do it
through children
uh
because you know unless we teach the
children
and their teachers teach the children
just the way you and i learned in school
and i learned it
i learned it right from the very
beginning
if not at home my teachers taught me
that the discrimination was was evil
and so
children get a lot of their education
and a lot of their morality from tv
so a thought might be to do something on
sesame street
that's that idea was brought up
and then that triggered other ideas
so if we can get to
to production houses who might want to
do their own thing and then give it to
us and then we'll take it to uh to fox
television in la and they'll put it on
and then we'll duplicate it and we'll
let people know across the country that
we have these series of spots and we'd
like to give it to them and would they
run it as a public service
and we hope it'll also remind people
not only to
be careful you don't discriminate
against arab americans or arabs
even if they have an accent
or people who are
of the islamic faith because of what
they've seen in television the r-e-e-l
arab instead of the r-e-a-l arab or
muslim
et cetera
why then we'll be doing a great public
service so we want to be able to to tell
people you don't discriminate against
anybody
because that's wrong
and it's un-american
so i think that's what we'd like to do
why is it that with these ads and during
vietnam and during world war ii people
did turn to hollywood for
maybe a sense of what it was all about a
message
in in the images that the celebrities
denote it's easy
you see when somebody
who is a celebrity
puts that celebrity on the line
it's not like a plumber making a mistake
and coming to my house and saying to me
mr cason i'm sorry
i said you got a little flood in the
kitchen because i i
did this when i should have done that
only one person knows he made a mistake
when a celebrity makes a mistake
or picks the wrong party or picks the
wrong cause
the world knows about it
so when a celebrity is willing to put
his name on the line his reputation on
the line and perhaps his career on the
line
people listen more carefully
what's next as far as the role that you
will be playing in the war in addition
to the the ants which you just talked
about
well i'll be at the rallies i'll
continue i have to go back to washington
or to new york i marched in new york in
october i marched in washington uh
last month on the 19th i marched here
just about every other week here in the
federal building or downtown at city
hall and i've given speeches i'll
continue to do
what i can on television shows
and radio shows to encourage people
to try to get the complete picture i'll
also encourage people to do something
else
people really are thirsty for knowledge
you know
it's not right to just say
they don't know anything because they're
stupid that isn't the case
a lot of times people don't know
anything because they're busy they're
working they're trying to keep a family
together
you know they're trying to feed the feed
the children and raise the family
so they don't always have the
opportunities that other people make
time for
like
going to alternative
magazines and newspapers like the
progressive
like uh
z magazine
like the la weekly
like the one in uh in new york the uh
in the village of village voice uh and
in these times and the nation
and uh
the oldest religious newspaper or
magazine in the country called the
churchmen and there's a catholic paper
too that's also progressive because when
you begin to read those
all of a sudden you find out it's almost
it's almost like
being a mind reader
two or three years after you tell people
what you already know
they say well how did you know that
did you read that in the paper no i
didn't read it in the paper i read it in
a magazine that's got a circulation of
about 300 000
at best or 30 000
and those magazines and those
periodicals don't end up on the doorstep
of mr and mr
america
so you almost have to look for them
or at least when somebody suggests
reading an article that is uh by
alexander coburn
uh by the washington post has a fine
writer coleman mccarthy who has spoken
out
i think as a as a progressive although
he may not be
there are a lot of fine writers
but we don't find them in the mainstream
press all the time
and we don't always find what we want to
read in depth in our pop edge
or in our in our columns
where people send in the sending letters
to the to the editor
just one final question we are just
about out of time but what image
stands out so far in this four week old
war
that
may
show people how you feel about what's
been happening
if they have children
for a moment
just for a moment
imagine what it would be like
with bombs dropping on you
if
they haven't experienced war
imagine what it would be like
in one of our tanks
or in the desert
facing
the same kind of missiles that we have
the same kind of armaments we have
with the possibility of cold seal
blowing your head off
or your arm
or your leg or paralyzing you
you see
war is the wrong word
coleman mccarthy had a
editorial on this a couple of days ago
he said let's change it from war
to slaughter
slaughter number one
slaughter number two
the golf slaughter
because that's what it is and if you've
ever been through a
a meatpacking plant or a slaughterhouse
and you see the blood running and you
see the death and you hear the screams
it's the ugliest thing in the world
we have to begin feeling
and not saying
that's ordinance we're dropping on those
people that's ordinance they're dropping
on our troops that's not ordinance
that's something that can blow you apart
casey kasem
thank you for spending some time with us
thank you
the c-span